a report from
the dog that is owned by my internet son
pft commenter chris i don't know how
much you follow this but leroy insider
the dog owned by pft commenter from time
to time breaks news on twitter now
i will say this
leroy is not batting a thousand so i i'm
always a little bit nervous i'm a little
bit nervous when i when i see something
leroy reports like the bears are having
dinner with eli manning uh that was one
that was uh that was posted by leroy a
few weeks back but but this one caught
my attention because it's not
implausible
leroy insider tweeted last night that
there are rumors that rob gronkowski is
going to come out of retirement and join
tom brady with the tampa bay buccaneers
now for starters that can't happen
without the patriots approval because
he's on the patriots reserve retired
list they'd have to trade him or they'd
have to cut him before he could become a
buccaneer but but assuming they could
work out the transactional side of it
could you see rob gronkowski choosing to
come back and play football with tom
brady in tampa
i could i could see him thinking about
it for sure i you know again
you know are two things that jump out to
me here you know one just watching what
was that wrestlemania two weeks ago or
just seeing little snippets of it or
maybe that was sunday i can't even
remember now the days you're running
together he does look like he's put on a
little bit more weight like he's been
lifting weights a little lately so
that you know i know he's probably doing
it for the the wrestlemania show but
nonetheless might have got him in the
mode a little bit to be like oh man i
missed working out this feels good okay
i feel pretty good and of course
training for that event in itself maybe
you know could have ignited his fire a
little bit and then also hey listen just
like brady kind of being worn out by the
new england way i i wouldn't be shocked
if that's what happened to the gronk a
little too where it just is you know the
grind of new england caught up to him
let alone the physical toll and he loves
brady we know that and you know they
have good tight ends in tampa they can
make a trade happen if they want it it's
interesting nonetheless i don't think
it's crazy
yeah you could send o.j howard or
cameron breit to the patriots for the
rights to rob gronkowski it's that
simple if gronk wants to do it and let's
also be realistic about it because you
and i were quick to call bs on the idea
that the buccaneers didn't talk to tom
brady prior to
the opportunity for them legally to do
so under nfl rules surely they were
talking to brady and would it shock
anyone to know whether or not
bruce arians the coach of the buccaneers
has maybe had some conversations with
gronk right and that wouldn't surprise
me either and for gronk bruce arians is
the perfect coach
gronk had gotten worn out by bill
belichick here comes bruce arians with a
drink in one hand and he's dropping
f-bombs and he's got the kangal hat on
this guy's cool in the eyes of rob
gronkowski this is the kind of guy that
gronk would come out of retirement for
especially if it puts him back together
with his good buddy tom brady i mean it
makes a ton of sense on the surface and
if they could work out this transaction
if there's a way to make that deal
happen i it would not shock me we spent
so much time last year speculating on
whether or not gronk would unretire and
play with brady with the patriots
obviously he ultimately didn't i think
now we're going to be on this idea of
whether or not there's going to be a
path for gronk back to brady to tampa
out of new england it'd be fascinating
if it happens yeah it would be
fascinating and you know like i mean i
think we made a lot of good points to
why it you know
is not totally out of left field i think
there's a lot of things that match up
that you go that's a positive i can see
that happening and you're right you know
aryans i just think aryans would be
a welcome refreshment to guys like gronk
and brady and brady brady will probably
be able to even help sell it like that
to gronk if he is thinking about it uh
but be interesting certainly something
to keep an eye on here because hey we do
know this too the patriots have a need
at the tight end position and of course
you know there's nobody that knows how
to use the tight end as good as new
england so they might see value in just
letting him go and get getting a younger
prospect like a braider oj howard
who do you want if you're bill belichick
cameron braider o j howard yeah that's a
really tough one i mean braid is a
little bit more consistent oj howard is
you know a physical freak in a lot of
ways and has some top-end talent but
just has not played
to the level that of course the first
round draft pick which we would expect
you know i think cameron breaks a little
bit more of a sure thing right now and a
little bit better of an all-around
football player
uh
yeah i think it would i think i would
probably favor break uh in a close one
yeah breit uh is a guy who emerged and
was having some good seasons before
howard came along he had 680 receiving
yards in 2016 and eight touchdowns then
howard came along in 2017 as a rookie
howard had 432 and breit that year had
591
but howard has been more productive the
past two years and last year it was 459
receiving yards for howard only 311 for
breit but brade is a guy they recently
redid a contract with may have extended
him more years into the future he's been
around for a while he's still only 28
though he turns 29 on july the 3rd oj
howard i look at it this way
he played at alabama for nick saban
bill belichick would be able to pick up
the phone and find out exactly what make
makes o.j howard tick in one
conversation with nick saban so
before belichick makes his final
decision that conversation is going to
occur and uh
we'll know
based upon which guy he wants we'll know
how that conversation goes with nick
saban if it goes well it'll be howard if
it doesn't it'll be camera break the
harvard guy who would be coming back to
the boston area if that's the deal that
ultimately occurs but it's not
outlandish it's not ridiculous it's one
of those things that makes so much sense
it may make too much sense and it won't
happen for that reason
right no i i'm there with you you're
right and you're right about the o.j
howard points a great point by you i
mean i wouldn't be shocked if
belichick's probably already had that
conversation with nick saban a few years
back and really knows what oj howard is
but yeah something to keep an eye on
here during the off season
there was some chatter last year about
o.j howard maybe being available would
it shock you to know if this were the
truth that before the second round pick
got sent to the falcons for muhammad
sunu that maybe they called the tampa
bay buccaneers jason light former
patriots employee easy pipeline there
hey jason are you willing to part ways
with o.j howard so maybe they've already
sniffed around the possibility chris
yeah no i think that's real too i think
there's a lot of teams that probably
sniffed around o.j howard last year
you're right that was a very real rumor
going around the nfl tampa being a
little disappointed with what they got
out of o.j howard the first few years of
his career so
yeah i i'm with you mike i think there's
a lot of dots to connect here that make
a lot of sense that topic by the way
sparked by a question on twitter from at
poundtown 10 who wanted to know whether
or not it was realistic as leroy insider
reported that maybe rob gronkowski could
be bound for the buccaneer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports